millions of people live every day with
severe pain it doesn't matter if you
start hurting today or if you're dealing
with an injury from 30 years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his gentle method of chiropractic care
can help
[Music]
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents false injuries we think
nothing about
what they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife
faye um oh it's been probably now eight
months ago
she started developing uh tiredness
fatigue
she had headaches she had nausea started
getting some adjustments
and probably after about three to four
weeks she started feeling a little bit
better
noticeably so and in about two months
um magically so to speak she was fine
tunuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients
young children
people who've been in bad car accidents
bad falls maybe we've even had surgery
before
up to 80 90 year old men and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two day work up day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests
checking every range of motion of their
spine orthopedic neurological test
posture
and then we're going to take digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best
type of films in our field i'm going to
study those i'm going to study the notes
so day two we're going to sit down and
i'm going to go over the findings and
listen if i can't help someone i'm going
to let them know and i'm going to get
them to the right doc
if i can help i'm very straightforward
how long is it going to take what's it
going to cost what's my insurance due or
not
do because if you're anything like me
you don't want financial surprises
and we're going to get to work and start
getting some relief as soon as possible
my life's changed immensely i'm
pain free where i used to have shoulder
neck pain i wasn't able to lift my arms
brush my own hair it's almost like a
relief when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's amazing
you heard dr devin talk about the
importance of the examine digital x-rays
well write down this number on your
screen because the first
20 callers will only pay 37
for both normally it's one hundred and
eighty dollars
call 702 566 hope
or 4673 you can also get more
information
at drdevin.com